[JON GREEN] So I'm Jon Green,
and I'll be presenting a
practical workflow for
AI coding assistants.
First of all,
I want to give special
thanks to Ray Saray and
Ali Karim for giving me
access to Claude Code,
which is what I built this
work-- workflow on top of.
And also Rafael Cruz
who tested out all the early
versions of this workflow,
and was very patient about it.
Also have a little bit
of a headache, so I might
be sitting down a little bit
more in this presentation,
but still I'll be over here.
So let's start.
Okay.
So I'm sure you've all tried
copy-pasting from ChatGPT.
We're gonna go quite
a bit far beyond that.
So, what we'll be working
with is an AI that is
aware of the whole code
base, has agents, can make
changes directly to the code.
So you know,
there's a bunch of them.
You've probably tried,
you know, Copilot.
You've probably tried
Gemini or Claude Code,
which is what this will be on.
Maybe even Kero or
Kero CLI, that's from AWS.
But I'll be focusing less
on the-- the tool, less on the--
the AI itself and more on the--
the workflow that I've
developed here.
So, why do we want to
use these AI assistants?
Basically, it allows you to
work a lot faster, so, you know,
these studies that I cited here
were using--are using copilots
which is not at the same level
as the AI I'm gonna show you.
It's not the same level
as--level as Claude Code
or Gemini CLI or you
know, other tools, 'cause
they don'-- like,
can access-- like, copilots,
can access the code, but not in
the same way as an agent that
can access the--
[TRUCKER HATCH] Command line, it
can run any command at once.
And I'm also
going to show you how to get
above 46% trust in the accuracy
by, you know, using tests,
test-driven development with
AI, and creating, you know,
test document specs.
But before we go into the--
the details, I think a demo will
help to show that, you know,
there's-- there's no magic here,
like, I'm-- I'm not a magician.
I don't wanna make it look like
I've got a bag of tricks here.
You know, I invite you to,
you know, look at the code,
but this QR code will take
you directly to the code
base on code.stanford.
So without further ado,
I'll just go into the demo.
So there's a few things I
just want to highlight here.
So, you know,
this is using
the latest version
of Claude Code.
I have some commands I built
into this, like this refresh,
which refreshes the context.
We'll talk about that later.
Basically it helps it
remember what it's doing
But, you know,
there's a lot
going on here,
but let me just copy
this first prompt here.
So this first prompt is
just to create a snake game,
and what it's going to use
is this task document.
You know, it's a spec that
I created beforehand.
In this spec,
there's no explicit code.
Sometimes there's some paths.
There might be a few tests in
here, files for it to look at.
But there's no code here.
A few configurations,
and what the AI's gonna do,
it's gonna read this spec,
which I verified and reviewed
before, and create a game.
So let me paste that in here.
Hello, one moment.
I rebound all my keys from my
keyboard at home,
so I'll just
do it the old-fashioned way.
There we go.
Okay.
So you see, just telling it,
follow this spec.
Also added a instruction
for it to time itself,
so we can see how long it takes.
And a game like Snake
isn't so complicated, but,
I don't know if
anybody could do it quite
as fast as this AI
is about to do it.
Is there any,
are there any
game developers here?
No?
Okay.
Oh, there's one game developer.
So.
Right now it's creating
the tests, I'll just
show you here.
Yeah, so it's reading the code.
It just created some tests.
So you see here,
it wrote all this
and it's going to
use it to verify that
the game is complete
before we even run it.
It's created some more tests.
It's running the tests,
to make sure they're all red.
They failed, which was expected.
So, this is already
quite a bit of work.
This is 80
lines of code here.
Let's see, oops.
There's 162 lines here.
So, within two minutes,
it's already created a
substantial amount of code.
And let's see.
Okay,
all the tests are passing.
I think we've got a game.
So,
yeah, I've been so this
game until now didn't
exist, this Snake.
It took two minutes.
Well, let's just go ahead
and run it, and there we go.
In two minutes we created
Snake, and has collisions,
works pretty fast.
There's self-collision, yeah,
you can add self-collision.
So
this is a complete Snake game.
Yes?
[AUDIENCE MEMBER] Yeah,
just curious did you start
off by like creating a
spec, a spec-driven
[TRUCKER HATCH] Yeah.
I started out by, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
So the question was did
I start out by creating
a spec, whether this is
a spec-driven development.
And yeah, that's how I started.
So I would-- I'll go into more
detail about that later,
but basically I have a bunch of
these for a bunch of games and
we're gonna build a few more.
But you know,
you create the
spec and then it
creates the code.
So that was pretty fast,
two minutes, one game.
How long do you think
it'd take to write,
to create all these games?
Have Frogger, Flappy Bird,
Minesweeper, Pac-Man,
Mario, a basic version.
How long do you think that might
take for a human developer?
Probably a few
hours, maybe days.
Well, let me run this here.
Set down the mic.
Okay.
So I'll just put that there.
So, I've written all
these specs ahead of time.
It's going to start 14
agents running in parallel,
and we'll see how long
it takes to do this.
We can see it starting up,
but we're gonna go back
to the presentation.
Okay, so I'm not a magician
and these--
so, I'm not going to
hide any tricks from you.
This workflow has basically,
you know, other than the
agent, has four parts.
It takes notes,
we have the tasks,
we have guides,
and we have tests.
And these work together to,
you know, create the software
mostly automatically by itself,
although there's a lot of
iteration that happens,
and we'll talk about that.
So, the notes-- so,
this is an instruction
I've told the-- the AI to do.
Basically, I'm just
telling it, you know,
"Take notes while you're going.
Just take notes."
You know, it's like a log,
an audit log.
It keeps track of the
errors it runs into.
It keeps track of the solutions
it comes up with, and this is
really important for context.
So, you know, the AI
will eventually run out of
space in its context window,
and we need to be able to
refresh that reliably.
The compressions, you know,
there's different ways
to compress it.
Don't work, you know,
completely well.
It always forgets
something important.
So, that's the main reason,
but there's also a lot of side
benefits you get from notes.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Uh, this is on
Claude at Stanford.
Uh, I'll show the,
the QR code later
in the presentation.
So let's go here.
So, I have it use these
kind of triggers, habits.
Basically, I give
it instructions.
You know, "This is when I
want you to, you know,
take some notes."
So, when it's gonna hand off
to me, I have it take notes.
When it makes a commit,
I have it log the commit
ID so we can look it up
and get history later.
Errors, whenever
there's an error and
just throughout the work.
Okay, and the tasks
is the other part of this
so, these are the
specs, basically.
They're to-do tasks.
Started out as a little
to-do list I had the
AI maintain for me,
and then it became-- you know,
I add more and more detail
until it became,
you know, documents
of their own.
And this workflow, you know,
kind of just evolved
organically as I developed
using these, using the system.
So, you know, in the-- the--
the code base I'm sharing
with you, it's-- they're all
kept inside this to-do folder,
that keeps a master list of
all tasks in the to-do index.
There's a specific
numbering scheme for tasks.
It even keeps track of priority
and the status of the tasks.
I'll show that in
the code later.
And, you know,
it's an iterative
process, creating this,
these tasks with the AI.
So like, start out--You know,
the task, it what you want it
to do, everything it needs to
know to create this task.
You start out just
telling it what you want.
It has instructions built in
to the prompt to the Claude
code like, claude.md .md
Like cloud,
the md file that
allows it to understand
how to create tasks,
and you know, like,
what to do with them,
and then you review.
So once it creates
the initial version,
you go through a review,
and it's just iterative.
Like, look at the document.
If there's something
there that you don't want,
tell it to remove it.
If there's something there
it needs, you add it until,
you know, you're happy with it,
and then after that is
the build process where
it's also iterative.
You know, with these games,
you know, I'll show you a few,
it creates a lot of them
in one shot pretty well.
Some of them,
like Mario and Pac-Man
will have a little, some bugs,
but you know,
that's the nature of these,
you know,
non-deterministic systems.
It's gonna create
a different game every time.
So I've run this,
you know, in testing,
like, half a dozen times,
and each time the game
is a little different.
So anyways, you know,
so you work with AI until
the implementation is what
you want, and then, you know,
deploy, test, document,
and eventually archive
the task, which has instructions
on how to do that explicitly.
Guides.
So, these are like
documents teaching it
how to do certain things.
So, this could be how to debug
webpage, how to patch something.
Like, for instance,
one of the websites I work on,
patching is a really
tedious process.
I've created a guide, and the
AI reads the guide, and then
it does the patching for me.
You know, there's a few,
it might not get
all the patches done,
but it does 90% by itself,
and I'll be demonstrating that.
As well,
later on.
One of the issues I
found with guides is security.
So, I create a custom
script that checks to
see if there's, you know,
secrets in the guide, you know,
passwords or other things.
'Cause it really likes to put
everything into this guide.
So you have to be
a little diligent.
You have to check,
make sure it's not
doing anything,
checking in stuff
that shouldn't be there.
And, you know, having
an automated script go
through helps it do that
before coming to you.
So you can say, you know,
run the verification script.
It will go and then
put placeholders
itself before you even,
you know, need to review it.
And then testing is another
part of this system.
The testing is kind
of a guardrail.
So, it's a guardrail,
it also helps it during
the development process.
So, having the AI create these
tests helps it,
you know, first of all helps
you be more confident,
which goes back to
that trust part,
getting you above the 46% trust.
But it also, I found,
has side benefits in terms
of keeping the AI focused
while it's doing the work.
So you can tell it, you know,
make a test for, you know,
making sure the items are
selectable, making sure,
you know, this or that work.
And it will put
that in the code,
and then it will
automatically run the
tests and find the issues
before even coming to you.
So it helps make the iteration a
lot faster.
The AI iterates with itself
for a while, and then you can
come back and do the real
testing and see, you know,
if it's up to snuff.
And you can even ask
it to make more tests,
which is also helpful
to prevent regressions.
'Cause often the AI will fix one
thing and then break another.
Or it'll fix one thing,
and then you'll add
another feature,
but it will put
back the same
broken code.
And it doesn't make any
sense, I find, you know,
if you'd make it, if you
have it write a test.
You don't get
that regression.
So, let's see how it did
over here.
Looks like it ran into a bug.
(laughing)
So this didn't happen
during testing but let's
see if it can recover.
But while it's doing
that I'll just show you,
it created all this,
like, all these tests just
while we were talking.
Created, you know,
most of the code for these
games, they might even work.
Okay, context is low, uncompact.
Okay, so this, let's try it.
So this is what I
was talking about,
the compact, looks like it, the
conversation's too long.
So, this is what I was talking
about in terms of context.
Is it not sharing my screen?
Look at this.
Sorry, I don't know why
it's not showing my screen.
Okay.
Okay, so now you can see
what I'm talking about.
So, this is what I was talking
about in terms of context.
So, basically what happened is
it ran out of space in the
conversation, and it looks like
Cloud Code can't,
there's an issue,
an error with Cloud Code itself,
so I'm just going to exit
and restart this.
Okay.
Let's resume.
Let's see here.
Sorry about this.
Continue.
Okay, now it looks
like it's gonna work.
Or maybe not.
Okay, I'm just gonna
create a new conversation.
Okay.
So this is a good
way to demonstrate
the refresh function.
So while we were talking,
it was building all this code.
It was also taking some notes,
or should have been
taking some notes.
Yeah, so, you know,
there's some bugs.
Of course,
they always
happen live
when presenting.
(laughing)
But see-- let's see if
we have Flappy.
Okay, so it did
create the games.
So you can see,
this is Flappy Bird.
Let's see here.
Let me just give it
a quick instruction.
Okay, so it's going to
look at the code and pick
up where it left off.
But pretty sure all these
games are gonna work.
Let's try running the launcher.
Okay.
So here's the launcher,
here's the games.
Let's see.
Does anyone have a favorite
game they want to see?
Galaga?
Pac-man?
Okay.
Let's let's
do Frogger first.
Okay.
So not 100%, but of course,
it stopped halfway,
so I'll just type it in.
Frogger.
Okay, so here's Frogger.
The cars, the logs,
and you fall in the
water, you die.
Okay.
So then, let's check out,
Galaga.
So, here we This is pretty good.
Just from a prompt.
We have lives, we have waves.
Geez.
They're not shooting, but,
you know, this is pretty good.
Pacman sometimes has
trouble, but let's see.
Yeah, this is-- this is okay.
There's some dead
ends in the maze
and doesn't fit exactly there.
But yeah,
if you hit a
ghost, you die.
So this is pretty good.
[AUDIENCE MEMBER] Can
the Citi have song?
[TRUCKER HATCH] No.
It doesn't do the song.
I could-- didn't want
to add that, you know,
too much noise during
the presentation.
But you're free to, you know,
copy the code and
add that feature.
You can use the task system that
I'm going to demonstrate next.
So, that's pretty okay,
so it ran the tests.
All 773 tests passed,
so-- you know, the tests,
obviously, you can see
how you have to iterate.
You know,
the Pacman
game had dead ends,
it was probably just
that one level,
and it didn't have
any of those power-up
Those
power-up balls.
So that would be
part of the iteration, but,
and you can see
in just a few minutes,
you can create something,
and then you can iterate with it
and you can create tests.
I guess the,
the next thing I'll show
is how to use the guides.
So we'll just introduce
you to this guide here.
This is kind of a spec,
basically, it's just telling
it how to do a process.
And you can see here,
it has this table of
contents, which helps
it find the things.
It's pretty interesting
to watch it go through this.
But you can see it has
quick refrences.
It has the list of things to do.
You know,
this is pretty complete.
So this is also an
iterative process to create.
And we're just going
to, we're gonna create
a game here together.
So let me paste in this prompt.
So, right now, it's reading it.
I gave it instructions
to read the guide
and then, you know, run it.
Okay.
So, it's asking
what kind of game.
I don't know.
Does anyone have a game,
like a burning, like,
a game they've always
wanted, a 2D arcade-style game?
Yeah.
Sudoku?
Okay.
Let's make a Sudoku.
Yeah.
Oh, maybe, does
anyone have a,
like, an interactive CLI game?
No?
Okay.
Sudoku, Sudoku.
And you don't even have
to spell these things right.
So, that's one thing I really
enjoy, just type in,
the faster you type--
[JUN PAGOTAISIDRO] Better.
Okay,
so now it's asking what
we want to put in the
v1 of this Sudoku game.
So, let's see.
One difficulty level,
pre-generated puzzles.
That sounds pretty good.
Let's just go with that.
Let's copy paste.
Paste.
Okay.
So now it's creating
the task for us.
So this is the idea,
the spec-driven development
you know, with the AI.
So first we're gonna
create the task itself,
then we're gonna have it run
the task to build the software.
Yeah.
So you can see here,
it's getting the number
for the next one.
So it's 17,
and it just
wrote the
whole thing.
Now we can, you know,
just go through and review it.
I'm sure it's probably 100%.
Let's see.
And you can see how it
has a testing strategy.
This looks pretty good.
Technical notes.
Yeah, this looks,
looks pretty good
for a Sudoku.
So it's gonna build
this in three phases.
Yeah, let's go
ahead and build it.
[JON GREEN] Okay.
Yeah?
[AUDIENCE MEMBER] So where did
it come up with the list of
requirements for this game?
Because you wrote the guide,
and the guide has enough stuff
to tell it that it has to
then have these sections
in the list of tasks.
[JON GREEN] No.
So, the way it did, oh, okay.
Okay.
So, the question was basically,
how did it know to write all
the tasks for the spec?
Because, you know,
it's because it, it knows
how to play Sudoku already.
So this AI already knows
how to play Sudoku.
We could create a more
imaginative different game here.
But that's how it
wrote the spec.
So, I've created,
you know, different games.
The guide I wrote here will
go through the whole process.
I have it ask for
specific things.
So, it wasn't, if it
had more features, you know,
it was different than Sudoku,
would have asked you, you know,
what the core gameplay
of it is.
As you can see here,
it has even an example of a
Zelda game built into the spec.
So it, you know,
it would ask you things
like these, you know,
depending on the game.
And then, it lists out the
different features it believes
that are going to be needed,
like either from your
description of what you
want or from its inference.
You know, of course,
it inferred basically
all the Sudoku game.
But if you wanted to build a
more complex game, you could.
So right now it's working on
the red phase of the tests.
It's working on the game.
So, probably be done
in a minute here.
Okay.
All the tests are passing.
Let's just type in Sudoku here.
Sudoku.
Okay, all tests pass,
the game is there.
Let's play.
So, there we have it.
Sudoku.
So, let's just try putting
a number down here.
I think one might go here.
Okay, cool.
So, oh.
Okay.
So, let's, let's go look at
you know, what, what--based
on, you know, this workflow
I've created what I think is
going to come down the line.
So today,
we have this
manual workflow,
which uses files
checked into Git,
you know, files that
are version controlled.
Down the line,
we're going to
have, obviously,
integrated tooling.
We're going to have different
things built into the IDE,
built into different agents
that the AI can use.
Further down the line,
we might have repositories
of, you know, context.
So you can pick up and
develop code on features
that you were working on,
you know, months before.
You might have--well,
definitely have ways for
non-technical users to
create specs and tasks,
and feed into the system.
Of course, we'll always need
someone to review those with
the technical knowledge, but
these are just my ideas of what
could be down the line.
[TRUCKER HATCH] The developer
role is moving towards
someone who, you know,
does a lot more reviewing
and testing, and focuses a
lot more on the system design
and architecture than, you know,
the nuts and bolts of the code.
You know, I've, I've had
projects where I've had to
change the programming language
because the library I was using
in the, the one language
wasn't powerful enough.
I just told it to
change, you know.
So, you know, and then,
of course, all I have to
do is review the code.
But it's a lot easier to review
code in a different programming
language than to, you know,
just learn a new language.
So here's the QR code again.
So, I invite you to
scan the code,
download the code,
and you can run these if
you have a cloud coder.
You can run it just the
way I was now during the
presentation, and build
all these games yourself.
You can create a Sudoku
or you can create a more
imaginative-- or you can
create a different game
using this task guide here.
And, yeah, that's
my presentation.
So, here's a link
to my LinkedIn.
You can add me and
we can connect.
Does anyone have any questions?
Go ahead.
[AUDIENCE MEMBER] Somebody was
asking about the specs, right?
How much time you spend on it
and how do you approach--
[TRUCKER HATCH] Yeah.
So basically,
a lot of my work
is now creating
the specs, you know,
I have to read and make
sure that they have all
the things that are required.
So you know,
it's a lot more
reading and reviewing,
but it's a lot-
[JON GREEN] Faster.
You can find like,
you write the spec and you
can find the bugs, you know,
before you write the code, you
can look at the architecture,
can make sure it doesn't create
something, you know, wonky.
You think at a higher level,
you know, it's not so much nuts
and bolts of the code anymore.
It's more like,
what do I want to create?
How's a good design for that?
So it's a lot more of the work,
but it pays off in the end
you know, in terms of the
speed of the development.
With these AI agents,
you can pivot a lot quicker.
You know, if you write,
like my example,
I wrote the code in
a language that didn't
have a library that was
as powerful as I needed for
the features that were coming.
I just changed the language.
I wrote a spec,
I told it, "You know,
we need to change the
language to this one
using this library."
And it went through,
looked at the code in
the other language,
translated it and put
all the requirements
that I asked it to put
in the spec into the code.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
So people are, you know,
I-- oh, sorry.
So the question was
"Is my interaction with
the code like a black box?"
And I still, you know,
read the code.
I still make sure it's good.
I still write tests
or check the tests,
but it's less about
writing code,
for sure, you know.
It's more like, "Okay,
this code looks good," you know.
"This code has all the
things I asked for it,
and it's passing all the tests."
So, yeah.
[MODERATOR] Can we jump
in with an online question
really quickly and then
we'll get back to you?
[JON GREEN] Yeah.
[MODERATOR] All right.
So from
Reynaldo "Jon,
I can see this
being used when the AI
knows the algorithms,
such as common games,
but how about custom apps
that is unique, for example,
to your business requirements?
How will you avoid coding
and rely on AI in that case?"
[JON GREEN] Yeah.
So that's a great question.
So that's where the iteration in
the spec becomes very important.
You know, have to, you put all
those business requirements
into the spec.
You know,
you work with it as it develops.
So you develop,
you're developing the spec,
you're developing the code.
It's collaborative.
If it's making, you know,
a webpage that doesn't,
isn't the way you want it,
you tell it to make
it a different way.
If it's trying to use the wrong
JSON structure, of course, you
have to step in there and tell
it to correct the structure.
So it's not hands off.
It's still hands on,
it's just different level.
You know, you're looking,
you know, making sure that
it's building the
thing that we want,
that the user wants
less than making sure
every line of code is,
you know, exactly perfect.
[AUDIENCE MEMBER] Thank you for
the presentation,
this was great.
One of the questions that
I have is regarding the app
development and next steps.
So once you develop the app
locally, how do you verify that
this is ready to release to
the App Store, and have you
experimented with the process
of submitting it to different
stores and is there any way
to make it platform agnostic?
So if I develop something
that I could release to the
Google or the Apple Store?
[JON GREEN] Yeah.
So like a mobile app?
[AUDIENCE MEMBER] Right.
[JON GREEN] Yeah.
Making an app or a website or
anything,
you have to test it yourself.
So, of course, then, you know,
you're not going to go and
just have it generate a
bunch of code and upload it.
You know, you have to test it,
like I have it create, you know,
a test suite so that, you know,
for iteration and
verification purposes.
You know, have to manually
test it before uploading
it into the, to any store.
Did that answer your question?
No,
you upload to the
store the normal way
you would and, you know,
you create the build file and
then you upload it to the store.
Of course, they could create
the build file for you.
And then of course
you would test it and
upload it to the store.
[AUDIENCE MEMBER ONE] I'm
curious about your experience
with dealing with, like,
structured data, like a SQL
database or any other kind
of databases that you have to
incorporate into an application.
Do you write those specs in
the spec in how it should
interact with the database?
Or do you have to use
something like a MCP to let
it know what tools to use?
How would you go about it?
[JON GREEN] So for a cloud
code, it knows SQL very well.
So what I would do is, you know,
create the schema in the spec.
I would say, you know, we need,
you know, these fields or,
you know, you could even go to a
higher level and say, you know,
"I'm creating-- a database needs
to hold this data," and then
have it create a schema, and
then just check to make sure
that that schema makes sense.
So you can either be very
specific and, you know,
"This is exactly what I
want," or you can be more
high-level and say, you know,
"I want something like this.
What would that look like?"
And, you know,
it depends on what
you're building.
If it's a system
that's in place,
of course you need
it to be specific.
But if you're creating something
new, maybe you see what the
AI comes up with first, and
then refine it or, you know,
correct it or, you know, yeah.
Good.
[AUDIENCE MEMBER TWO] Like,
cloud code, would-- is there
a better agent that works
better with?
[JON GREEN] I've only Used
Cloud Code for databases.
But all the LLMs,
they're trained on,
you know, vast amounts of data.
I'd be surprised
if any of them didn't know
how to write SQL code.
So this is, you know,
the system that I
have access to.
Uh, I've tried a few others.
Cloud code is
the best that I've,
I've tested so far,
but that doesn't mean it's
gonna be the best tomorrow.
You know?
You know, there's Gemini,
that's also very good
and has a free version.
Um, there's Kiro that
Amazon was just doing a
demo of, and, you know,
I'll have to revisit that one.
It looks like they've added
some features to that as well.
So you just have to keep
on trying different ones.
You know.
And see what one is
good in the moment,
'cause this is just
changing so fast.
So--all
[TRUCKER HATCH] All Right.
I think we've hit our end
of the time for the session.
Uh, can we thank
Jon one more time?
(applause)
If there's any more questions,
is there any way
we can reach you?
[JON GREEN] Yeah.
You can reach me via
email or LinkedIn here.
You can add me on LinkedIn,
using the QR code.
So, yeah.
[TRUCKER HATCH] Awesome.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.